[Music]
in cannabis city news bar adi gives a
[ __ ] buckets in this room colorado
submitted by I love JK and thank you
you're so nice this is so good
marijuana complete but an entire town
and hopes to turn it into a destination
for cannabis assistance it's like a
cannabis Disneyland
alright the whole town what is it home
it's like Vegas what's the name of this
marijuana company uh it is co why you
know of
I just wanted I'd even know America a
marijuana companies are conglomerates
now so now I'm interested somewhere Oh
what is it like [ __ ] Sears marijuana
or something I think it's such a mall
bro
it's such a booming industry now that
they're just gonna [ __ ] dominate yeah
probably about on all the names of these
are will probably in green American
green got it so they have bought this
town it's in California it's between
California and Nevada
yeah like is it close - like Riverside
bar star on that area doesn't straddle
Nevada though it doesn't that's
California side ok here it is it's near
15 wells near the 15th no it's on the
way too big it's about to sprout it's
warming up - that's pretty smart though
because now there's two two destinations
you can go to so if you go to Vegas you
can stop by Nippon get hot dancers
that's why they did it and that's
probably why we did it - event land is
cheap it bought the town for like $5,000
you're close
not really five million that's really
cheap for a towel whole town how big is
a town uh-huh so they have a hundred and
twenty acres of land and includes a
school building a hotel mineral baths
and a general store and has a population
of 20 people what did you do there 20
people and there's that much [ __ ] going
on yeah
maybe all the neighboring people come in
to hair
oh [ __ ] it needed some renovations dad
California this place needed some lovely
hotel and eat go there's all these cute
ass Turtles boughs of skyscraper devour
nipa skyscraper that's tight ya know
you're sleeping on all these my belly $1
no it's your attitude you try and impose
and I don't want the desert all my land
is tropical or cool that's expensive
but I like the Arizona desert or the New
Mexico desert the intense desert don't
want I don't want a California desert
but I like to visit there because when I
Drive there I go this is what meth-heads
look like with a broad brush this town
it was originally founded during the
gold rush it looks like it yeah and then
the gold rush went down it brushed away
from it there's no more gold you have
good one-liners today yeah the project
manager of this company he said quote we
thought that showing that there was a
viable means of having a cannabis
friendly municipality and further making
it energy independent could be a way of
really inspiring folks to say why can't
we do that here because they're also
trying to make it cannabis and green
friendly so all around
oh really it's gonna be HIPAA down the
goldrush built the city the green work
rush can keep it moving the way people
envisioned it years ago what this twenty
people that's like the size of JK being
a town town you just need the right
investment you are the town technically
but I don't know about the desert
you want the desert
I don't care let's just do anything
right now no I don't want the desert
sorry you want that baby in the hot Sun
I mean there's no beach oh I could make
a beach there yeah what he said
yeah see you're thinking too small man I
could turn it into a beach yeah so they
want to invest 2.5 million in
revitalizing it and they're just gonna
try to make it more tourist friendly
like I mentioned before there they're
trying to really make it green friendly
too so have everything like
energy-efficient awesome I told my mom
selling weed was not a bad idea dude and
was it legal I was 14 or 15 and then I
grew a little bud plant and then my
mom's like that's so illegal and I'm
like yeah but I'm thinking about the
future one day it's not gonna be legal
and it's not that bad you really felt
like one day would it be like yeah I was
like were you so convinced I just felt
like it I just wanted it to be that well
see you weren't convinced you were in
hoping and then my mom was like you're
you're gonna you're gonna be in big
trouble don't do that that's a crazy
life and I was like have you smoked weed
and she's like no and I was like then I
rest my case you don't even know the
joys of it and you're like okay well if
you guys smoke please smoke in the
garage and I'm like you're [ __ ]
awesome what's your mom told no because
like she's like I rather have you
smoking here then going out there I
don't know what the hell you're doing
out there smart yeah and she no she
couldn't control me by that time because
I was already taller than her and I
could beat her ass if he tries to beat
me at
you changed the piece instead of s what
plans do they have here like I know
they're trying to make it green but do
they have like specific businesses that
they're trying to pull in or is it like
are they trying to build like condos
like are people gonna live there or is
it just slowly like solely like what is
it Las Vegas music slowly
yeah like Vegas come slowly known to be
the best where it's cuny skinny touch
where you drive in you do you're [ __ ]
this mother day like you do all your
[ __ ] and then you just leave like how
they turn to someone I want to know that
to it I don't know [ __ ] it took me so
long to know that I feel like it's gonna
be like a marijuana town where they have
like edibles you might have a hemp
wallets and products I think it's just
like all around marijuana I'll create a
marijuana resort where you can kind of
come here sit in a Jacuzzi can that's
genius very calmly I mean is gonna be
stayed cuz everyone's gonna be too chill
to do anything [ __ ] up yeah I want to
raise my kids they're [ __ ] nipton I
don't know about that I do cuz when have
you ever met a [ __ ] up stoner it will
be the messiest town on earth mmm why
because toners are lazy I've never seen
a clean stoner that's meth so you need
to have a name well there's already a
lot of meth heads in the desert what you
gotta do is employ the meth heads to
come and clean the Tara they come in and
they're the janitors they stare they're
[ __ ] mopping okay this is not jaqen
office so they stay up late anyway so
you have the meth heads while all the
stoners are sleeping at 7:00 a.m. the
methods come in I [ __ ] clean up the
streets and then they go scatter in when
the Sun comes up it's back into their
trailers right and then the stoners come
out the zombies come out
we and then they [ __ ] smoke they have
a messy room messy Street they [ __ ]
throw their trash everywhere they're too
lazy to clean it up and then happens
again meth heads in the middle of the
night are you paying the methods in meth
well yeah I guess I don't know they're
gonna they're all over the desert
together in a month with one truck and
like doing a home depot a whole bunch of
them together if you ever see a white
guy that's super red and you know super
red super skinny super jittery in the
desert I can guarantee you he's a meth
head and he loves to organize and clean
every woman's dream come true I think
it's gonna be the best town ever a
marijuana resort with net head cleaning
crew put the fat head cleaning crews
gonna be green in other ways but there's
solar energy no that's that's so cool
faster yeah I want to see it happen I
don't want to see what they come up with
you know what I picture in my head I
picture toontown Oh like a hamster damn
like it was lava lamps in every business
like that it just looks cute yeah
everything's just goofy like goofy
looking I don't picture that I prefer
gonna be green for some reason it's the
green toontown is when I'm picked white
Rastas everywhere with the like yellow
black and green like hippie thing and
then those plaid shirts and so is their
flag very organic feeling like a tie-dye
their state though they're just a city
flag the town flash state flag would be
a pair no dude town that's like maybe
this town will have different types of
stoners like you got you got the hip hop
crew you know like you've got the you
got the black people stoners you know
and then like the Snoop Dogg's and [ __ ]
you know they they have their style and
then you got the [ __ ] you got the
hippie kind of stoners and then all the
all the white people right here they
like to drink their
jeez and [ __ ] and they got they like
to grow their plants and all that [ __ ]
and then you have like more of the the
Asian stoners kind of blend into the
different like groups you know but then
but then mainly you know yeah you can
have your Asian stoners but I think
Asian stoners is like they like the
foodie it up and then I don't know about
the Middle Eastern stoners I think they
got to do it in secret because there's
like Ramadan and stuff and they get in
trouble but other than that I don't know
melting pot melting pot of STONER
stereotypes oh it's not gonna be pumped
in [ __ ] gonna be the opposite in your
world right it's gonna be a segregated
City of but the cool thing is you're
allowed to go to different parts you
know if you want to visit like hippie
town hipster town like la ya Doug town
hip hop town whatever town I hope you
guys enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]
[Music]